everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and I'm really glad to
be back I'm miss y'all I was in New York
City for free code camp Top Contributor
party and then before that I was in Salt
Lake City for react rally so if anybody
has any questions about how all that
went let me know I can answer that when
we do question answer sessions and then
at the end of the stream I'm still a
little bit exhausted from it all because
it was really awesome but I have very
little sleep from basically like
Wednesday until yesterday that's a small
amount of sleep but I did so much
awesome stuff and so I'm kind of excited
for what we were working on today it's
it's pretty cool we're gonna continue on
with what we're doing in the last stream
so in case you didn't see the last dream
I'll give you a quick recap
and also if you're totally new and you
haven't seen any much stream so let me
take a minute just to explain what we do
here so I am a full-time front-end
developer employed by a small University
and this I livestream my daily work so
these projects or projects that I'm
actually working on the project we're
currently working on is the new main
website for the University so it will be
Franciscan ddu when it launches these
are not exactly tutorials although I
hope that you all learn something from
them I certainly learned a lot from you
when I do them and so as you watch it
really the value in this is just seeing
what what it's like for me as a
front-end developer and seeing how many
mistakes that I actually make every day
and I still managed to keep my job and
how I work through those mistakes and
how I make decisions for projects so I
do my best to explain things as I go
along and feel free to ask you know any
questions I don't think I've ever had
anybody ask anything that I didn't want
to answer so feel free to ask questions
pretty much nothing
offends me I think that's it oh so I do
Pomodoro sessions through the stream so
we'll do 25 minutes of coding and I
won't really answer questions during
that time and then I'll take five
minutes answer questions we'll do
another 25 minutes a session of coding
and then at the end of the stream I'll
take all the remaining time to answer
any questions that you all have so if
you ask a question it seems like I'm
kind of ignoring you don't worry I'm
only ignoring you for a little bit I'll
get to you at some point okay so here's
what we're working on today so we have a
react project okay so a website
progressive web app that's running Reax
which is a JavaScript library and we
need to create a contact form that when
a user fills it out they put in their
first name last name email and then
whether they want to be undergrad
graduate or online student at this
university we need that data to be sent
to Salesforce and automatically create a
new record for that student in our
Salesforce database or you know however
you wanna call it
so last week they're our last stream we
successfully created records hey but we
we didn't make the form yet we just kind
of did it all and hard-coded it in the
backend with in our with nodejs
in our server dot JS file okay so today
what we're going to do is were number
one we're actually going to create the
correct records because if you remember
we did get to send data over but it it
went to the wrong place so we're going
to try to go to the right place this
time and we're gonna try to actually
create the form so that we can fill out
the form on the site hit submit and
hopefully have it have everything work
okay so that's the plan for today we'll
see how much of it we can get done
I'm gonna go through real quick and just
say hi and see if there's any questions
I should answer right away before we get
started and okay so hey everybody I see
some some new people some old people I'm
just gonna say hi all at once because
there's a lot of people saying hi oh
[Music]
cool so lab says they use Salesforce a
lot to automate stuff awesome so maybe
you can you can help me out as we're
going through this all in all asks what
type of job I'm doing I think I kind of
explain that let me know if I didn't if
you have anything more specific that
you'd like to ask
let's see Stephen asks why I didn't get
interviewed at the meet and greet for
free code camp we just ran out of time
that was all and I kind of wanted to
hang back because I figured y'all get to
hear me talk all the time some of the
other people you know are just kind of
behind the scenes so I figured it'd be
cool if they had a chance so I kind of
waited and thought if we have time I'll
get on there otherwise you know y'all
can ask me whatever you want
okay so let's get started I should show
you my screen first that would help
alright so here's what I've been working
on and let's see alright so the latest
thing that I've done that's different
from the last time is I've I've changed
out a few things so number one I got
these environment variables working so
they weren't working the last time and
there's a good reason why they weren't
working because I didn't require this
this dot end okay so I needed her to
bring in that package first for this all
to work so once I did that now it worked
so our file with the environment
variables now it works now what this
does mean is if you're working on this
project locally this will not work for
you so once we get the form up and
running if you try to actually submit
the form it won't work because you won't
have Salesforce login info which there's
not really anything I can do about that
if you wanted to kind of use this on
your own project you'll have to have
your own Salesforce account and set that
up
and down here what I've done is I've put
all of this code that we use to send
data inside this server dot post and the
the path now is inquiry - submits so
we're gonna send from our front end
we're gonna send a post request to
inquiry
- submit and then it's gonna take that
data that we send and it's gonna use it
here so for now I'm just hard coding
because we're gonna test it out with
some hard-coded stuff just to make sure
that it's creating a record in the right
place with the right information and I
didn't start my Pomodoro timer let me
start that and while we're here I just
wanted to show off so a colleague of
mine Liz who's awesome and super smart
showed me this website that she made
when she was out of like ten or eleven
so I just want to show it off I'm I'm
kind of impressed this was from 2001
like I don't even think I had a computer
when I was 10 years old so I mean shoes
are already making websites using HTML I
like it
so I thought I'd just show that show
that officer shoutout to Liz thank you
for sharing and thanks for giving me
permission to share this on the stream
so if any of you like are struggling
with some design ideas you know feel
free to use this as an example alright
back to the code let me make this a bit
bigger for you it's probably way too
small I should probably start the server
your dev fingers dead
all right
that is probably big enough for now so I
think before we were sending we're
sending the the data as I don't know
what it was and something else I think
that correcting the Senate as is contact
so we're gonna hopefully that'll work
and I have all the fields here except
the last field which is going to be
either graduate undergrad or online but
I'm not sure what that field is exactly
so I'm gonna leave that blank for now
because that's just gonna take me like
going through all the fields possible
and trying to figure out which one
matches up I'm not gonna do that on the
stream because that's super boring and
we don't really need that to prove that
this will work right so let me save this
I was hoping we get some Auto formatting
on this but I guess not yet this is okay
though
why I really thought we would get a lot
better Auto formatting anyway I'm just
gonna change this to single quotes just
to get rid of these squiggly lines is
they always red squiggly lines always
look so angry you know oh now we have
some formatting okay cool
so our our next step here I guess what
we can do now is just like move this out
of here and just call it like right away
so let's do that
so what we'll do is grab basically
we'll grab all of this I'm just gonna
copy it and then paste it here will that
work maybe actually let's let's take it
out of there I'm gonna put it up here so
this should just run right with this
we're like automatically just calling
all this so this should run as soon as
the server restarts and then we can
check well we'll see what comes up we
should get an error message if it
doesn't work so this will be our first
check if it works then let's we'll move
on and we'll actually create the form if
not we'll switch it up try to make it
work so let's save it
this should auto restart all right cool
we got some stuff in here invalid login
all right let me I have my end file open
on my other screen all right so let me
double check that I have the right stuff
in there so unfortunately I'm not gonna
be able to show you this because then
you'd have my password so it'll just
take a second
okay and so just put my password in and
now I'm gonna get a security token so
when you go to put in your password here
but it needs so like up here this is
actually going to be if you're trying to
do this on your own your Salesforce
password that you login with and then
you're gonna combine that with your
security token and that will be what you
use
so let me I'm just gonna completely shut
this server down for a second and then
start it back up we're still getting it
closed invalid username password
security token huh all right
that's a little bit weird because we
this worked before
the only other thing I could think of is
resetting the security token also I have
this
check out this swag I got it reactor at
Aliso Apple was there giving out free
stuff and so I got a cool cup have some
iced coffee in there right now all right
let's do this so I I do have two
different security tokens one of them I
thought was invalid and I thought I was
using the right one let me try the other
one if neither one of them works then
I'll try to create a new security token
and I know I have it up somewhere on my
other screen sorry I have to do all this
on my other screen it's really no no
other way around this
mmm-hmm I think I deleted the email with
my security tokens where's the trash
there you go deleted items where are you
that would have been what day Thursday
yeah I think we created that first
soaking on Thursday oh where is it
all right I don't know what happened to
it so I guess we're not gonna try the
old the old one well do you know what I
may have had it saved
let me go back to that info see if I can
just go back to the original see if
it'll work all right I'm gonna say that
now and see this hmm
oh you know what I know why it's not
working and this is silly so in my end
file originally on the last time we
streamed which you know what it wasn't
Thursday because I was at that
conference it was probably Monday well
it's been a while so last Monday I just
named them username and password but
when I redid some stuff in here and I
changed the name to Salesforce username
and Salesforce password because I
thought you know it may be off to put
more stuff in this end file and I I want
to make sure that it's clear that these
are the Salesforce username password so
I'm gonna change the names here and then
everything should work
all right and I think I you just like
they're very cool a different error nice
all right so here we are we we went in
successfully and it looks like we have
an invalid field all right I was I was a
little bit worried about this there's no
such call in this first name
okay
I scroll down here so alright let me
look in Salesforce and I'll see if I can
show you I'll I'll pull this over and
show you but if there's any student
information I can't so
yeah you know what I think I may end up
looking at student information so I'm
not going to show that live I'll just
like describe what what I'm doing here
so my music stops on Spotify so let's go
back
okay
alright let's bump this down so alright
so let's try to just do this let's say
name let's try to run it with this name
invalid field why is it still it's still
saying first name why I just changed
that oops
you know what I probably changed it in
the wrong spot that's why yeah we we
copy and pasted it up here so maybe
that's why
now that what's the race [ __ ] let's try
it again
oops
he totally shut the server down and
started up
I don't know I had this one running
going too that's why I kept running
everything twice let's get rid of that
okay
all right let me check to see if this
even you know came in at all
it's I don't think anything was created
let me check my time all right we still
about by nine more minutes and so I'll
go back and answer questions all right
so let me look at this a bit more
mmm-hmm if a name or was it capitalized
I can't remember if it was originally
capitalized or not so I'm gonna try it
out with being capitalized see if it
does makes any difference at all and it
doesn't look like it does
please check the security settings of
this field okay
[Music]
and if I can
I need to find in Salesforce where the
state is going
all right we might just skip might just
skip to the actually making the fields
in react because at this point I mean we
know we know we're connecting to
Salesforce
the problem is just making sure that
we're we have the right keys for key
value pairs for our data so that's
that's just gonna have to be me going
through Salesforce and trying to figure
out exactly what what these keys are
because to be honestly it's not exactly
clear and I'm not the one that set it
all up so maybe I just have to get a
hold of somebody else so let's switch it
up a bit and what we can do now is get
rid of get rid of this so we don't have
this run every time we we save something
let's go to was this gonna be you know
what let's make a totally new component
for this because I think we'll have this
on on multiple pages so let's go in here
and check out our components so our
components folder and we're gonna make a
new file and we'll call this inquiry dot
J s it's gonna be the inquiry form and
let's just pull in some code from
another component maybe let's just pull
in the code from this this hero
component just something just to give us
a little boilerplate right and we'll
take probably one grid will definitely
want button Styles probably don't need
typography we'll leave it in for now
though just in case alright cool so we
can leave that alone we'll come back to
these in a minute what I want to do
really with this is move this down to
the bottom so we've been doing that with
all our components moving all our styles
down to the bottom so as we as we edit
things we're doing that a little bit
easier when you first go into a
component to figure out what's happening
if you don't have to scroll down through
all the styles first let's change our
name so instead of this component being
hero we're gonna make it oops not gonna
be able to do that
hero we're gonna make an inquiry so we
have to change it here and then also
down here
inquiry okay
right now it's passing in a lot of props
for now I don't anticipate this
component having any props so let's get
rid of all these props and we can get
rid of a lot of this so all these
options okay and now within our return
we can really get rid of pretty much
most of it right almost all of this so
yeah tell me we have our basic stuff
here we're gonna leave em let's leave
these button styles just in case we we
want to reuse them I'm not gonna need
this parallax yeah
actually now I think about it there's
gonna be we're probably gonna have one
prop and I'm not gonna worry about it
right now the props gonna have to do
with if we place the form on a section
of the website that has a white
background that we're gonna need the
button to look different than if we
place the form on a section of the
website that has a dark background
not only the button but all the the
color for all the phone everything so
those might be the only options we might
basically have like a light and a dark
theme for this form but for now this is
gonna get it worked in so we're gonna
start out with a grid component and this
is going to be a container and inside of
that we're going to have some more grid
stuff so we're gonna do a grid and we're
gonna give it Coop's that's my timer all
right we'll stop here let me take a
short break and go to the chat I'm gonna
scroll all the way up to the top of the
chat and try to get through as much as I
can Steven says that dry erase board is
nowhere near big enough just sayin so I
have a dry erase we're behind me can't
see it in this view but yeah actually I
haven't used that dry erase board for i
from at least a year so I don't really
use it that much I used to like sketch
things out on it but I write I just use
paper now
all-in-all says all of your courses are
really cool thanks for everything you
did for free oh you're welcome you're
welcome thanks for saying that I
appreciate that Andre says hello from
Portugal hey how's it going thanks for
joining us Niranjan says hi how to be a
front-end developer and what should I
have study if you want to be a front-end
developer I would start out with the
free code camp lessons start with those
and then kind of branch out from there
and supplement with YouTube videos and
books as you go on but that'll give you
like it'll ease you into things very
nicely and it'll hit a bunch of topics
that you will need to know and then
figure out what you like and then you
can specialize from there but that's
that's my advice
to get started
Ezekiel says how are you John Hansen
says hi how's the hand
so my hand if you don't know I had
surgery on my wrist a few weeks back and
it still hurts I think it's gonna hurt
for a couple more months before it's
really better so it's okay I made it
through carrying bags and stuff through
lots of different airports and I could
do it I mean it hurt but I could do it
so in terms of like having the strength
to actually do things it's there so I
think I'm gonna try to start like
working out a little bit and just see
how much I could do probably this week I
started back on my diet again this week
and I mean I'm not gonna be so extreme
like the last time I went on a diet I
was really trying to lose weight and I
dropped like I don't like fifteen pounds
this time I'm not really gonna try to
lose weight very fast just kind of like
kind of slow and maybe they just worried
just worried about like eating healthy
building muscle and things like that but
I'm gonna see how much I can do with
this risk for now
v-pool says what's this 93rd part of
project five or just part two of the
title okay so it's part two of us
working on with the Salesforce API but
it is the 93rd installment of project
five here so yeah I've been working on
this for quite a while
Sanjay says hey it's been a while since
I caught up with the stream what project
are you working on currently this is the
main website for Franciscan University
so it's a react project
so use a react node WordPress for
content management next j/s so we got
some server-side rendering going on
custom routing so that's that's what
working on John Hansen says high-five
for building a new component cool yeah I
think it's always cool too I think on
the stream to build a new component
especially for those who are starting
out and are new with react because like
the more times you go through that
process and see it just the more
comfortable you'll be with with doing it
and for me to like it if I get like I
haven't really done much coding for the
last week so I don't want to get too
rusty yet kind of doing things although
I rarely code a component from scratch
I'm always copy and pasting things which
i think is a good way to do it it's
efficient
near eyes says how do you learn
programming well there's a lot of
different ways to start out if you're
interested in doing the kind of stuff
that I'm doing here I would definitely
start with the free code camp exercises
so check out free code camp org and go
through that but there's so many
different types of programming it kind
of depends on what you want to do so if
you let me know what you're really
interested in maybe I give you something
more specific you know somewhere to
start out but all right cool so my timer
is up and I'm gonna go back now and
we're gonna do one more pull Medoro
session working on this before I go back
and answer some more questions and
that'll probably be the only coding we
do for today we'll just be this next 25
minutes so let's go into this grid and
now that I'm looking at this I think
it's probably easier if I copy and paste
some grid stuff from somewhere else so I
don't have to try to remember or look up
what to say
alright so you extra small I'm trying to
find a grid that has everything that we
need here all right I guess I'll just
copy this for now and I'll guess it the
other one so what I mean in particular
is this like for extra small screens we
want this to be 12 and then I'm guessing
small as the next one let's try 6 for
small you'll see what I'm doing this in
a second if you're not sure what what
we're doing this for let's see and then
within here this we're gonna want to put
some form elements so let's check out do
I have I guess I don't have any any
windows here so let me pull over I
actually could use this let's pull this
out and now that I have this dark theme
on here I can't see where this corner is
area
all right let's go to material UI calm
so we're using the taro UI for a lot of
our design for this site it comes with a
lot of free made components in the
material design style and what we want
to find now is our inputs so let's go
it's gonna show us the API but really
what I want is a demo so we want the
textfield demo first let me make this
bigger so y'all can see and we can
actually make this like really big will
do fullscreen and this is what I want I
want these components but I want to do
the controlled version so I believe it's
down here oh maybe they changed it
all right well let's just start with
something basic
so we'll just grab I need a placeholder
probably not I don't really need a
placeholder so we'll just grab a basic
text field and we'll move it over over
here and so we want to import this text
field component and then we're gonna
bring in the text field guess what we
need and I guess we could put this all
within a form or not I don't really
think it matters for the way we're doing
this but let's check this out for now
they'll just bring in a text field and
okay so our text field here let's clean
this up a bit we're gonna say give an
idea first name and a label of first
name and we don't have classes for
textured yet I guess we could import
those we could copy and paste them over
value is gonna be this state first first
name how about we just do like this
first name like that this one change
this handle change first name okay so
that looks good let's pull some of this
stuff over so we definitely need the
handle change and we need our state's so
let's pull this alright we'll get our
styles to it in just a second and we'll
pull those in
that's that we were supposed to do this
yeah we don't need this we'll have to
change these up a bit so we're gonna
have first first name and then we're
gonna end up having last name last name
and then this will be email and this
will be student type I'm not sure what
to call that yet but eventually we will
have that and for now these are all just
gonna be blank and did we have an
example with a control component is that
what I just saw
let's also grab that text field here and
pop that down here okay it's they great
all right so that should work
we don't have classes we need to set our
there we go
please ask questions if I'm going too
fast or skipping through this way too
fast but this this is just gonna allow
us to instead of to having you type this
props all the time now we can just type
classes it just saves a little bit of
space and then if we add any other props
which we probably will we can just add
them in here and then we can just use
them straight away like that so I
believe this is called object
destructuring and I think it's an es6
thing all right I'm gonna take a breath
for a second because I just went a
little bit you know fast so I'm gonna
take a breath and explain a little bit
about what's going on here so we have
our text field the value of our text
field is going to be determined by the
value of first name in state but what
will happen is
when we type in this field on change so
every time we type something in here
it's going to call this function called
handle change and it's gonna pass in
first name and what this will do is say
ok we'll take the name right of whatever
input that is because we're gonna have
more than one and we're gonna set state
to whatever that value is now so
whatever is typed into that input is now
going to become the state here in this
case our first name state so anytime
state changes in react because they
rerender of the component so it's gonna
rerender and when this component goes to
re-render it's gonna say ok what's our
value and it's gonna look back in state
and now our updated value in state is
going to be the value for this so that's
the way the flow goes when you use a
component it's called a a controlled
input all right
controlled component right so that the
value is actually controlled by the
state so a little bit different than if
you just have I mean even if you were to
control things through JavaScript maybe
if you're using jQuery the value would
be read and changed directly but in this
case it's it's state that really gets
changed and then everything flows from
there so we don't change the value
directly we change state state causes
state change causes rerender and then
value comes from state hopefully that
makes a little bit of sense once you use
it a few times if you're not if you
don't already understand what's
happening if you use it a few times
you'll you'll understand it makes a lot
more sense ok so now that we have that
one in here let's copy and paste
and we're gonna use three of these
inputs and we'll just switch up the
names here so this was this one who easy
we'll just switch it to last name
oops
last name and then this one will be
email
okay so let's save that and see what it
looks like so I am I'm running this
right yeah so let's go to local hosts
local is 3000 and so we actually need to
use this component so let's add this
component right onto our homepage and
see what it looks like so I don't think
I have a homepage up here let's go to
our index and on our index first we'll
import this so let's just grab this for
now copy and paste it and then change
this to inquiry inquiry and then now
down here we'll just pick a section
let's see what this looks like see we
should put it
I guess we could just throw it right
below one of these top sections degrees
yeah this is gonna have its own grid so
let's put it inside yeah let's just add
it as another text section there's
another section here and it's gonna be
inquiry and we have no props to pass in
right now so let's see what happens cool
and here it is pretty terrible right now
but at least we we have our inputs let's
type and we could see a it's working
things things go in there if we really
wanted to we could look in dev tools and
see that the state is actually changing
but I'm just gonna trust that the state
works right now since otherwise we may
not even really see anything so great so
we have our fields the style of this is
awful right now right but we're not
worried about the style we want it to
work first so let's add our last section
in which is going to be a drop-down so
first we can just make now let's first
let's go to material UI the
documentation again and let's find let's
see there's gotta be one for a drop-down
or select selects there we go so we want
to put in one of these selects it's just
gonna look like this so we're gonna do
kind of same thing again then grab some
of these so we'll imports
this select and select I don't know if
we need that or not yeah and this handle
changes actually it's made a little bit
different so we'll probably have to
change up the way we're doing things
hmmm I think I might like this way
better
we'll see if we'd switch it to that way
because then it's one less thing we have
to pass in here so let's see we have
okay let's go this this whole thing here
and we'll probably have to pull over or
form control as well but we're gonna go
with another grid there we go and we're
gonna do the same thing here that we did
with the other ones and these are just
the columns so on an extra small screen
this will take up 12 out of 12 columns
on a small screen and up it'll take up
only six out of twelve columns so it'll
be 50% width and then over here 100%
width we also need to import form
control import label and menu item let's
go up here and just grab these
I don't need the helper text okay we'll
just verify that that's actually showing
up yep it shows up and see we can check
here now we can change things up a bit
so our name is going to be what we call
this student type we'll give it an ID of
student type and our values so this will
say under undergraduate graduate and
online
and then we'll replace these with
undergraduate graduates and online okay
all right now you remember I said we're
gonna have to change something so
currently our handle changes expecting
us to pass in the name but what we could
do
Olivos
so here frame for pros we are giving it
a name of student type
all right let's let's just do it then
like like this I kind of wanted to
switch it up so that the text inputs use
the same thing as this one but for now I
think this will be the fastest way to
get it working student type okay now
let's save that oops
keep going the wrong way oops I forgot
to change age so instead of age let's go
with
student type and I'm gonna change it
here shouldn't type and one more time
student type okay whoa
and this is way too small
let's pull over I guess some of the
styles for this
I mean maybe the form control will pull
over see what that does for us area okay
so now we have this so this is all that
we need in terms of inputs for our form
we will need a submit button okay and
let me check my time oh about five
minutes okay let's let me grab some code
from a previous project to speed things
up so in the the Resource Center project
that we did that was a react project we
we have a form on there it's a much more
complicated form but we can use the same
thing so we had a handle form data let's
put this in here and it's going to be
crazy at first right but because we're
gonna do handle form data we're gonna
create a new noise form data it's not
define anyway
we'll see how much of this we can get
working before the timer's up probably
not gonna get it completely working but
you know at least we have someone a page
now all right see how I said we had the
state structured here okay
I see so we actually had we don't need
any of this file stuff rights because
we're not uploading files yeah this will
be cool actually to have a loading thing
come up so we'll leave that in even
though we don't have this in the page
yet and we're also gonna leave this this
fetch in there
and our upload URL will be for now what
did we set it in our server
what was this inquiry submit so upload
URL will be increased submit okay and
we're gonna send a post request and then
the data we're gonna send is just gonna
be data right so this constant this new
form data okay and then we're gonna do
some stuff depending on the response
that we get we're gonna do some
different things cool we're gonna have
to add in some of this dialogue stuff
which I'll probably just copy and paste
from so if you want to check out the
full code of what we were doing it's the
service request j/s is the file name and
that's in the Resource Center project
under the views folder so it's service
request is I'll just copy and paste the
link in case anybody wants like the big
picture of how it all fits together okay
all right cool so the mainly the part
the only part in here that I'm really
worried about right now that will
actually do anything or work at this
point is this here right this is going
to what's going to send the data to our
back-end now this particular way of
knowing things with the form data it's
gonna work no matter what we add with a
form this small we could probably just
hard code like here's what I want to
send in there and just form that object
ourselves but well since this is already
in there and it should work we'll leave
it in there what we won't need to do
though is adjust the way the state is
structured here so instead of just state
like right off the bat we'll have to say
form and then within form then have all
these right so it's gonna mess up our
controlled components
for a little bit we'd have to set it and
make sure that we have we're getting the
state from the right place
you know input you yeah this is just a
lot more complicated if you check out
that link you can see that that's a much
more complicated form so definitely more
than we need for this one and my timer
is up so I'm just gonna save this for
now even though the changes I just made
are gonna it doesn't look like it's
broken but in reality it it's breaking
some stuff behind the scenes now I'm
gonna go to the chat and I'm gonna
answer whatever questions remain in the
live chat and then we'll finish things
up
near eyes says how can you help me in
programming well if you watch this dream
I'm sure hopefully you'll pick up
something helpful there are a lot of
tutorial videos though on this YouTube
channel that may be more helpful to you
if you're just starting out so check
those out for sure gym Punk's is built
from Windows now I'm actually developing
on a Mac right now oh oh
what's a gun I'm really sorry if I
mispronounced your name let me know I
should pronounce I'll do my best
next time but anyway that says what
exactly you're trying to develop in this
particular stream I'm trying to create a
form that sends data to our nodejs
back-end and then from there it sends
the data into Salesforce overall for the
entire project we're creating a website
for university with react node graph QL
WordPress for content management so
that's that's the overall project Victor
says you are awesome Jesse thank you I
appreciate that today Charles is here
Charles as well how's it goin Charles
david says coding live is the best
exercise awesome cool I'm glad you like
it it's definitely I hope it's useful
for you all it's it's so helpful for me
I learned so much from you all and just
having to explain what I'm doing also
makes me really think about like why am
i doing it like this and it kind of
keeps me like really honest and soft me
from stagnating you know like if there's
a better way to do something in a newer
way like I'm gonna try to use it just to
save myself the embarrassment of being
caught you know live in front of all of
you using
you know outdated stuff okay program
missus remove the forum it gives you an
error the : I think programmer I'm not
sure
[Music]
I'm not sure exactly what you were
referring to then is this when this was
here I assume you're talking about form
like fo RM so I know yeah this will
cause trouble for now I'll need to
adjust some things to get this to work
or I can go back and not do it this way
I'll see I'm not sure what I want to do
David senses you are the best programmer
here I kind of doubt that I appreciate
you saying that but I I definitely doubt
that I know there are a lot of you that
watch the stream that are just awesome
you know I'm just I'm a programmer
that's willing to show everything that I
do and let you all see all my mistakes
and everything so if there's anything
unique about me you're good about my
programming that's it it's just some I'm
willing to put it all out there and that
might not even be a great idea to do but
that's that's what I'm doing and I hope
it helps you out and it also in terms of
like being a good programmer to be
honest with you there's so much
information out there too I think it's
more accurate to say like this person is
really good at this particular thing you
know it's it's so hard to judge like a
good programmer you know like what do
you measure that by so it's more like
you know what's your expertise you know
certain people are better at certain
things and it's it would be I don't know
if I want to say impossible because you
never know but it'd be really hard for
one programmer to be the best at a lot
of different things you know so I think
the the goal for for those companies
that can afford it having a team of
programmers who each specialize in
certain things is the best way to go and
just realize that one person is not
gonna be able to do it all you know
let's see
Zach KZ ACK says are you using XJS I am
I'm using next
Lamia says hey hey how's it going who
she says remove this warnings I'm not
sure what warnings you're talking about
so let me know and I'll I'll check into
it
Razvi says mob eggs yeah and I'm not
using my bags so that would be like for
like state management so you could use
my bag so Redux actually we're not we
don't really need that right now I'd be
kind of overkill for what we're doing
right now since we're using Apollo
though we can use Apollo to do very
similar things to which you would be
using mob X or Redux for so that's
probably what we would go with Alexandra
says what theme do you use the theme is
called SETI SETI Stephen says I feel
differently it's not that I learned from
you as much as I gained an understanding
of how you use it at work and that the
struggles you have are the same that I
have see the work in the actual work
setting gains more insight than just
another tutorial it's not that I don't
learn stuff it's more job insight on how
you work with it cool I I I'm glad you
said that Stephen I I totally think that
that's that's the value of what I do is
not necessarily that you learn a
programming concept you might but the
the goal with more or less is just to
see how how I do things like really at
my job you know because there are a ton
of tutorials that are pre-recorded and
edited and and really kind of efficient
that can teach you a certain programming
concept better than this stream will but
for this dream you know you'll you'll
see what my process is actually like I
mean I don't know if I'm like the
average dev or not I have no idea but
you'll at least get a view and how I do
things
and hopefully you know you you may think
hey well you know if this guy can get
paid full-time to be a developer then
certainly I can write you know it might
help you get a little insight low
confidence you know and especially for
all you or maybe freelancing or
programming on your own remotely or
something you don't really have the
experience of working with other
developers like like pretty much that's
been my experience as well so I think it
just is just cool to see how other
people do things all right cool
so I finished up with all the questions
so I'm gonna wrap things up here and
thank you all so much for watching oh I
got a few more questions let me answer
this last question and then I'll wrap
things up Steven says so how much time
outside of work do you spend on work it
really depends on what's what's
happening so if I have a side project if
I have a side project and I'm working on
then I may spend you know hours every
day after work actually doing work like
right now I don't have a side project
and I'm getting paid for I take that
back I have a very minor kind of ongoing
like project that I do with a client
just like maintenance stuff you know but
that's only like literally like maybe
like a half hour a month or it's less
than an hour a month I do own that so
that's that's not a big deal so at the
moment I'm really not doing anything
outside of work so I'm taking a little
break finished up a different project so
we'll see but it just it totally depends
on what I happen to be working on let's
see
Julio's is working on project for school
setting as well excited to learn thanks
for sharing knowledge oh yeah no problem
Raza says do you like Express Jas more
than sales Jas Ordonez Jess I like
Express but I've never used sales or
Adonis so I can't really give a fair
there so those may be awesome
I just don't know I've never used them
but I do like working with this Express
I've been able to figure everything I've
wanted to do with it I've been able to
figure out how to do it so I mean I I
can't really ask much more from you know
package or framework you know Stevens's
being new to development I find myself
working a lot at home yeah I mean it's I
think to be honest with you I would work
a lot more from home if I didn't have a
wife and kids really because I love what
I do and I love learning more and making
cool things so I would probably be
spending almost all of my time
developing things like literally I would
probably if I was trying to be healthy I
would have a workout in there which I
should every day and I would have time
to eat but other than that all my time
would probably be spent programming
right so it's good to try not to get
burnt out and make sure that yeah you
have some other aspects to your life
just you know kind of manage stress and
things like that so but it's definitely
that what that's gonna look like is
gonna be different for different people
and whether or not that's healthy is
gonna be different for different people
right so it's hard to say like overall
you know what how many hours are too
many hours right because it just it
depends on a lot of factors so like for
me working all day is not healthy for my
family right probably not healthy for me
but you know even more so it's not
healthy for my family if I didn't have
that if I was single you know then maybe
it might not be as as big of a deal
maybe I could work longer hours and that
would that would be fine
all right because it's not like it's
work for that long that's something I
enjoy doing
sooo Rob says step by step explained
docker and Jenkins please sir I don't
know that I'm that I know enough about
docker and Jenkins to explain him step
by step so you probably don't want me
doing that maybe try to find some videos
there may be some videos about that on
our free code camp YouTube channel but
check out learn code Academy their
YouTube channel so it's I can't believe
I forget his name I forget the name of
the guy who does that channel but the
channel name is learn code Academy will
stern I think he's name is wolf stern I
know that will has some videos on darker
and I think you have someone Jenkins so
check those out they're a little bit old
but the concepts are still the same so
those may help you out Charles says what
are your tips for getting a developer
job alright so just a few tips I'm not
claiming to be an expert here but these
are things that I've found are helpful
so always be working on projects that
you have on github and that you can put
up there people can actually see them ok
so employers do like to see that you've
worked on projects right - definitely do
that try to network with as many people
as you can if you can meet people in
person great if not Twitter is a great
place to get in touch with other
developers you can then if you there's a
job at a place where another developer
you like let's say you have a
relationship with another developer on
Twitter right and then you notice like
hey they work at this company and you
want to work there you could then ask
them for a recommendation and that
recommendation will get you farther
right so for instance like at Google if
you submit an application no one's even
going to see it at first it's going to
go through their program that kind of
wheats people out so a real person may
never even see your resume but if you
have a recommendation they have a
process
we're like that resume is guaranteed to
get into the hands of somebody to look
at so you've already kind of skipped
that first step by having that so that's
a great way to kind of get in there then
I would say like apply for as many jobs
as you can be smart about it don't spend
all your time doing that so get on
places like LinkedIn or like indeed comm
Stack Overflow and set it up so that you
can do like the one-click apply for jobs
so you know have like a generic type of
resume and then go through and every job
that's one click apply so not every job
is gonna let you do that but every job
will let you do that that's even
remotely in your range of skills apply
apply to everything it'll only take you
a second just to click and that way like
hey you you might get it you might get
an interview even if you end up not
taking that job at least it's good
experience to go through the interview
process so that's my advice if you do
find a job that you really really want
then there's kind of more strategies
that you can take to get that job so
like tailoring a project just for that
company for that job based on what they
do you know maybe getting in touch with
more people that work there and figuring
out you know what you need to do is so
like but it's in general if you're
trying to get a job and not like a
specific job at a certain company I
think the advice I just gave will be
okay
and I'm there probably a lot of other
things you can do but just from top of
my head that that would be my advice
okay
Elvises oops I'm sorry I skipped some
questions david says how many
programming languages do you know I'm
new with this I'm learning Python now
but I want to learn another programming
language in the future I really I know
JavaScript pretty well I have done
things with PHP with Python with C++
with C sharp and with Java also with
solidity yeah and I think that's it so I
have a very basic familiarity with a lot
of programming languages I wouldn't be
confident to say I'm gonna build all
this stuff but I'm confident enough to
say like I could kind of figure out
what's going on if I see some of that
code but for me I'm focusing on being
really good at JavaScript which seems to
me like it will help me in my career
more than knowing being like average at
a lot of languages or below average in a
lot of languages so but it depends on
what you want to do with your career so
it may make sense for you to learn more
than one language but for me I'm I know
a little bit about you know maybe five
or so languages and I'm trying to focus
mainly on one no this is what's the best
friend invalidation you'd recommend
[Music]
remember we use something on some
previous projects I forget what we use
so i'm i'm blanking here if i remember
in the next few minutes i'll let you
know but I can't remember what we'd used
before I don't remember what it's called
check you can check out some of our
previous projects on the github repo so
it's it's linked in the description so
if you just check up like the whole
github organization and look back at
some of the projects maybe you'll find
what we've used
Stephen says yeah I have a wife and kid
it's been hard at times about being the
only front-end developer you have to
learn it at some point I find that at
home I'm a little better at learning new
stuff yeah I mean that's
they said that's just some balance that
you're gonna have to make with yourself
and you know your family to figure out
like what's a reasonable amount of time
to spend knowing this right because you
know you like you need to be able to pay
the bills and provide for your family so
you need to be good enough at your job
that you're going to be able to keep
your job and and progress but you also
want to actually spend time with your
family too so that's a hard balance like
I don't have that figured out you know
we just do the best you can I just try
to do the best I can sometimes I do a
good job and sometimes I don't so can't
really give a lot of advice other than
just keep trying and keep talking your
wife and figuring out what's working for
her and you know just try to try to work
through that INF says no js' versus PHP
what's your opinion I'm a rookie
back-end I personally prefer nodejs to
PHP but it really depends on what you're
trying to do so in terms of learning PHP
like if you get a job that has to do
with WordPress or Drupal or Joomla or
anything like that you're gonna need to
learn PHP if you have the opportunity to
build new stuff and you don't have to
worry about all that then I would go a
node cuz if you're gonna be full stack
like why not learn node you can oh you
can learn JavaScript really well and
just use JavaScript front and back-end
so I yeah it really depends so I mean I
don't know all this you know specific
details about which one is faster more
efficient I don't know about that but I
prefer note Stevens's totally was not
qualified for this job they took a
chance and decided to give me a shot
loving the change so much way less
stress more freedom to us yes that's
cool well I'm glad you like this job and
you know do your best to keep keep
learning i mean i'm if they decided to
give you a shot i mean that at least
they have a little bit of patience right
that so hopefully you know the
you learn and and start to get really
good at it
mark Lynch says have you ever have you
used MongoDB before I'm trying to figure
out how to build my schema so it's
easier to work with can you recommend
some vids of yours or others also any
vids on testing since I know nothing so
we have done some stuff with testing on
some my previous videos but I'm no
expert on testing we have done some
stuff with [ __ ] I don't think we've
done it on the video though I think it's
on a side project that I work with it so
I would say in both cases you probably
want to find some other videos check out
free code camp just do a search through
the free code Kent videos to see what
they have I do know that once again will
Stearns
YouTube channel called learn code
Academy does have some videos on [ __ ]
and I also believe on testing so you may
want to check that out with most of his
videos they are a little bit kind of
older but the concepts are still you
know pretty solid so I I like his style
and in his videos it helps me up
Aki says what's the demand for of UJS
react and angular I'm from a beginner I
don't really know I'm to be honest with
you there's I would say out of the three
react is growing really fast and there's
a lot of jobs for reacts but angular
also has a lot of jobs but it's not
growing as much so I don't know which
one isn't first in terms of total jobs
reactor angular but it's close that it
seems like if reacts not already in the
lead it's gonna be in the lead soon view
definitely comes in third in terms of
total jobs but it's also growing really
fast so that's that's my take on it
right so I and that's just from what
I've seen I haven't really done a lot of
research into that so if somebody knows
better than that please let us know in
the chat ok cool I'm gonna finish up for
real this time thank y'all so much for
watching and I'm gonna try I'll probably
be able to stream tomorrow I'll be back
in the office so I'm thinking maybe
around the same Sun tomorrow and
yeah so until then have a great day